[Music]
all right who here is familiar with uh
what's been going on with donald trump
bart talk about it go ahead bart
talk about the prison bart's had the
latest bart's been to mar-a-lago i have
yeah yeah where's mar-a-lago it's next
to hawaiian gardens
[Laughter]
whenever i heard mar-a-lago
i thought it was like in spain or some
[ __ ] now it's in florida
keys right
over there uh is everybody kind of
familiar with what happened i just know
like they raided his house to find like
sensitive dogs dude he stole the bill of
rights man
donald trump
stole the declaration of independence so
the national church people were looking
for it at his house he's at the white
house he goes i like this this is very
american can we bring this here he's
showing all his buddies at mar-a-lago
like you guys wanna see some cool [ __ ]
that's worse of independence
it's in his bathroom check it out
he's gonna smoke it
yeah what was the whole thing about was
it like did it have anything to do with
the the
january 6 insurrection thing
yeah it hasn't specifically said
anything about that plus at the end of
the day these are classified documents
so i don't think any of us will ever be
privy to truly know what they are
however it's been said that um
basically when he was switching over
from you know
uh not being president not being
president yeah
they just [ __ ] took a bunch of
classified documents and stuff and moved
it over to his estate in mar-a-lago and
that's just like no you're not supposed
to do that there's up to apparently
anywhere from 300 to 700 different pages
or files of classified information so
when you take a document that's like
sensitive like that are you taking the
actual one-of-one paper or are you just
like copying the file now are they still
using paper i don't i don't know if it's
so much
again this is an assumption i doubt it's
like a one-of-one element but i think
the idea that there's even classified
and or sensitive information no longer
with the commander-in-chief
even if they were a former you know what
i mean uh it's more like
probably a due process and rights thing
to be like this this needs to be kept in
this
facility for the like you know person
who's supposed to be
working but now we have to ask what kind
of documents did he take what would he
take to me it's like i have a hard time
understanding like i don't okay so i
don't imagine trump
holding a file cabinet
to his house bringing it there right
like i'm use i'm gonna [ __ ] look at
these files later like it's one it's
probably one of his staff members
bringing it there for whatever reason
does he even have knowledge of it did he
call the shots on it
because then he used to go huh or is it
dirt oh i heard that it's like a bind
smear it could be a bind smear campaign
like get out of jail free cards like hey
i'm going to use this to be president
again leverage um no what i what one of
the things i also read was uh biden is
just trying to destroy his name as much
as possible before 2024 comes around um
it's a it's a future play yeah you
thought it was going to make it to 2024
though
no but seriously like that's a real
question election-wise no like life-wise
you're talking about our president bro
but it's like he's unwell
you don't think he's unwell
i have the beholder geez on top of him
having one of the most stressful jobs in
the world
like
remember the pictures of obama before he
went off yeah afterwards i mean he
looked pretty good now yeah but now he's
paddle boarding though and [ __ ] oh yeah
like he's he's living my age that's what
i mean yeah think about joe biden his
state like he's a he's a he's a very old
old man
and i get worried about him like as like
but obama worked so hard capturing bin
laden you know
[Laughter]
there's no bear here using drones and
drone strikes dude so uh basically the
uh the august 8th search was undertaken
to look for official records and
material from trump's presidency that
the national archives and department of
justice believe was improperly taken
from the white house when the former
president left office
now fbi has raided mar-a-lago and all
that stuff and pulled about a bunch of
stuff however
today
trump
is now
suing the u.s government over the fbi
search for mar-a-lago as the
ex-president seeks to prevent the bureau
from reading the seized documents until
court officials weigh in
so people are
conspiring or believing that the suit is
more so
a procedural thing to delay
the actual ability for uh you know fbi
exactly
[Music]
um
so he's followed the suit against the us
government
sources are pretty much saying that the
suit argues that the court should
appoint a special master usually a
retired lawyer or judge because the fbi
potentially sees the privileged
materials in its search and the
department of justice should not itself
decide what it can use in its
investigation
the suit filed in florida district court
also requires the government to provide
a more detailed receipt for property
and requires the government to return
any item seized that was not within the
scope of the search warrant that's
reasonable because it's like what if
they took the classified thing that
trump had maybe epstein's list or
whatever just saying you know and then
they're like well we could forget about
epstein's list but the other [ __ ]
don't you mean so the the suit isn't
working in the fbi's favor yeah
um a judge gives trump until friday to
better explain why he wants a special
master for the mar-a-lago documents so
basically i think now it's just kind of
like a diplomatic uh and judicial kind
of
dick measuring speed game right now and
who's going to be able to be in a
position of power before something
is given up some sort of information is
revealed either in a public court or
whatever there's like something so uh
boring about hearing [ __ ] like this go
down and then you just don't get to know
any of the real meat yeah i don't know
what i hate that [ __ ] yeah i wish i knew
it's just like the epstein it's like hey
all this stuff happened but you can't
know any of the details just it happened
and we don't know
who was on the flight list we don't know
any of that [ __ ] you're just like this
guy
is the worst guy right i know what i
mean what did he do i can't tell you
that's all you man you can't talk about
it you're like what the [ __ ] dude i bet
you it's not even a big deal like you
know at work you have to like do things
you have to like turn in your uniform
and like give your book back he probably
just forgot to turn in some paperwork
it's like when you steal the stapler
yeah it's like oh yeah dumb [ __ ] boom
they're freaking right against house
because like you didn't do this properly
and then what is it it's like these are
these are you know like day off request
forms right like
the classified info is really cool yeah
look at this really
you know conveniently disappear or
conveniently distracting us from
something else but i really don't know
like aliens like aliens
break dancing aliens
windmilling
i didn't i can't believe i didn't notice
that
you didn't see that [ __ ] alien yeah
52. yeah they're the real true rulers of
america
great just america don't break break
dancing aliens
just b-boy aliens come down they're like
we only want to rule this country
we will leave even canada and mexico
alone
alone
by the way pay attention to the list
that's it show us the less son of a
[ __ ] it'll never happen sure what's the
classified files
uh we said the wrong words there was
this xcia agent that was on lex
friedman's podcast and he was talking
about it and and lex friedman's like so
what do you think about jeffrey epstein
like
why do you think they're not going to
talk about the list things like that and
he goes it's probably 100
that jeffrey epstein was like a plant by
the cia or like the massage he's like
without a doubt
everything that he's been doing is like
because
apparently the fbi they kind of they
kind of operate in the [ __ ] gray the
fbi and the cia they get to like do
illegal [ __ ] all the time and then be
like what are you talking about they're
created good yeah exactly so i think a
lot of times they probably just covered
up their ass and was like all right this
guy was our guy let's [ __ ] kill him
and then that's that and we're not going
to talk about it ever again
so we're probably never ever going to
hear about the list
unless [ __ ] jason bourne comes out of
hiding unless donald trump releases
those files
[Laughter]
he's the savior
dude that would be some weird [ __ ]
that would be so funny and he vlogged
the whole thing we didn't even
everyone's on here
everyone's on the list
i have a picture with them i said after
that i found out i said he's a scumbag
no way
yeah the american people must know i
can't tell you who's on the list but i
could tell you in the cold outside i can
run for two minutes straight
stupid dude
was he trying to like jab at biden's
like [ __ ] like bike fall when he was
saying or no i'm i'm literally just
quoting jason from the board there's
four exits in this building four exits
in this building 47 steps to the door
i know how to steal a car
trump's accent's pretty easy dude
i never thought it before the first time
i tried it once i saw this hillbilly
dude i was like he could do it yeah he's
in overalls man fingers by the way with
cheeto flavors
spicy cheeto fingers okay okay you gotta
do the okay sign this is always okay
about the world okay and then you just
say
you just make a statement in two three
words
and they just yawn one you just repeat
it a bunch yeah repeat like
very great very very great
very fine people fine fine people trump
impersonation breakdown like how to
sound like trump i think we just did it
right now dude
we just got it
[Music]